[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum sometimes I think
about it too much am I should that be
like insanity with Michael Rose mothers
or be real happy hey les something no
one wants to listen to someone who's too
happy do they was that true but welcome
I hope you guys had a good week and
things are a little crazy with the you
know California's getting shut down
again beaches last weekend we're closed
and you know I'm not gonna go on about
this just thought things were getting
better and you know Joker's Joker's
cause this Joker's house everybody's
anxiety this week is everybody holding
up are we exercising are we keep into a
routine are we we go into therapy oh
yeah talking to someone we'll be talking
this out by the way check out these new
pillows holy crap Alison made these for
me and I want to thank Leah too for
being amazing look at this out of
t-shirts she made these pillows I love
them inside of you pillows thank you to
all my patrons especially during this
whole time when you joined patreon
you're helping the show Ryan thinks you
I think you Bryce thanks you thank you
for supporting the podcast going above
and beyond by just listening it you're
amazing but people who join patron the
amazing community and I can't believe
how many people have become friends on
this on this thing if you're interested
go to patreon go to inside of you under
patreon it's it's an app and support the
show if you like also shout out to
Ronald McDonald House Los Angeles and
all over the world they're everywhere
and they're so important in helping
families and kids going through
treatments and food on foot org you know
I love them shout out to my buddy Rob
and I don't know if you saw my glasses
Sarah made them for me they were amazing
the it was like a Luther and
a Kent and it was a decanter that we
call him a decanter for alcohol pretty
neat I had a yeah it's just is just cool
so those are awesome
you know status quo man just um you know
just trying to keep busy I guess it's
crazy I think I'm busier you know on
this whole lockdown thing just get the
feeling like you know you see friends
all the time then when you don't see
friends you getting a little depression
and you're a little bit anxious and then
months go by and then you're like I love
them I miss them but I'm kind of used to
this stuff that's not entirely true I do
miss my friends but the longer you don't
see them you know it's like [ __ ] I don't
even know it's like hanging out with him
I mean there were a couple people that
I've seen but not many trying to abide
the dude abides oh you know what I also
I had a good cry I had a good cry I was
watching Titanic you guys ever seen
Titanic I know you've seen times some
people I never saw those we want to see
it's I realized why I mean James
Cameron's just extraordinary but I'm
watching it and at the end you know when
the old woman she's there and she's like
you know she goes back into the Titanic
in her mind she's older and it's near
the end and all I thought she's just
trying to think of Jack and those
moments and all I did was think of my
grandma you know cuz I talked to her
face time almost every day and she's
like I miss my RV you know I miss my
grandpa I miss my grandpa I wasn't her
grandpa but she's like I miss my RV I
you know and I made these big signs for
her at Staples because when we went to
the funeral back in November I was like
I don't want this to be just boring and
tables and food so I had these pictures
blown up to these giant poster size and
they'd like four of them but me and Irv
on a go-kart an airplane just cool stuff
and she still has them next to her bed
and she has them in the house and
because I talked to her via Everyday and
it's just so sweet but anyway that scene
in Titanic made me made me tear up and I
love my grandma call your grandma's well
yeah call whoever tell them you love
them it's easy just here look at this
you just dial
let's just try to get it right now real
quick hey I just want to call you and
tell you I love you I love you too yeah
Oh how much on a scale from 1 to 100 I
was hoping you'd say like a thousand hi
you say from 1 to 100 Touche Touche
Blanche hey listen I love you I just
wanted to check in I'm doing my podcast
right now but I want to just see how
you're doing are you holding up all
right you're holding up for me
yeah you busy right now no but I thought
you're doing something oh yeah again
you're quick all right well I just
wanted to say hi and and take care of
yourself and I can't wait to come see
you all right you will okay all right
seeing you I love you I'll talk to you
later
all right see how easy that was I just
thought it and did it do it right now
you'll feel good terrific podcast today
thank you guys for you know you hear it
all the time but thank you I wouldn't be
here without you
um if you're sitting there and you're
like I'm just listening to this one
because I like Rebecca Mader or Beck's
made her she calls herself and many
people call her that as well we find out
why but if you're watching it for her
and you like it please subscribe
you know subscribe on YouTube you could
watch it listen on most any malysh is
great to listen to it anywhere and I
appreciate the support also the in situ
you store cool stuff cool shirts cool
hats all that fun stuff and I got a
mention old Napoleon Dynamite Jon Heder
and I have our horror patreon as well
another patreon called where have all
the good horror movies gone and we're
having a blast with that we just did a
zoom with all the one of the tears and
we do like a monthly as you know we talk
about what we want to watch and what's
up it's just a nice it's like a it's a
horror club
if you're a horror fan so thank you for
all my horror patreon fans and inside of
you patreon fans inside a podcast fans
people who just listen and love let's
let's jump right into it man let's get
inside the fascinating amazing she's I
love lost let's get inside
up Rebecca mater it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
oh she's sweet I should get her on the
podcast - she's great she's sweet I met
her a long time ago did you work with
her
sarah michelle gellar and then I moved
back to New York in 2012 because I'm
like I'm gonna die alone and we
reconnected there we had a really good
time
why don't you say you're gonna die alone
what the hell does that mean dating in
LA yeah well if you see me looking at
things that's because I I'm like I said
I'm doing all this postpartum titties is
that what you just said are you drinking
a brain sleep so dating I like how you
say that I mean it is terrible people to
understand in the world in general
dating sucks right but then in Hollywood
I mean give me your worst story in LA
Rebecca Mader what is it what's the one
thing though cuz one that's the reason I
pissed myself laughing because there's
one specific thing that just went it was
a classic it was I want to say the year
was like 2010-2011 I've and I was I was
current I was on lost at the time and
I've been single for a long time and I
was going back and forth to Hawaii I'm
like I should make an effort today
kukuku and I found this face book called
Brits in LA do not I mean like oh cool
I'll meet some British people they all
live in Santa Monica whatever like go
down the pub and then this one guy asked
me out on a day and I'm like okay and he
turned out to be such an arrogant wanker
and he was there's a picture of him on
Facebook next to a plane and then he
said the entire meal
I was really bored and then he said to
me what do you do for a living then I'm
like oh I'm an actress he's like hmm so
anything you know I was like oh no this
is awkward so I was like yeah I'm
currently on last and um what you
serious I'm like yeah you oh and he was
I swear to God he was devastated it was
like he was so annoyed that I was
actually successful I wasn't like it
what the waitress is like oh my god
you're amazing join a blow job at the
end of dinner
he was so guarded his whole face and
energy just went and in that moment he
just checked out and I just wanted and
it was the most uncomfortable sushi I
thought you're gonna say all of a sudden
he heard you say lost which was like the
biggest show ever back then and one of
the biggest show still I thought he was
gonna say something like his whole
demeanor his whole disposition was just
gonna change and then from there on he
was just really sweet you emasculated
him with one word and also in LA I was
finding that you know I was looking to
get married and have kids and I was
going on dates of people so much older
the thing and they're not ready to get
married and have kids how much older
yeah all right so I moved back to New
York to see if I could find a boyfriend
and potential you know baby daddy and I
got that and all my [ __ ] across the
country I didn't tell anyone I didn't
even tell my agent on my managers I
literally just shipped all my [ __ ]
across the country cost like $6,000 and
I just moved to New York I'm like I'm
gonna find a real person
it's down-to-earth it's gonna be great
and it wasn't it wasn't as bad as LA but
it was equally [ __ ] in a different way
because now now that it's become so gen
tracks I used to live in you
New York like 1998 to 2006
and I had an amazing time in my 20s but
then when I went back in my 30s and 2012
it's totally different and everyone in
Manhattan all of those were either a
lawyer or a banker oh god yeah that
doesn't you also were married before yes
when I was in my 20s in New York I got
married really young and it was that one
of those things where you guys did were
your friends did everything work that
was it nice and then it just fell apart
or was it kind of a spur-of-the-moment
thing you get you get all hot and heavy
just really really good friends you know
he was a really good friend and we
became more like roommates and mother
and sister what happened so it's kind of
like a slow dissolve for soft fade to
black you still friends friendly you
know and friendly and I'm sort of so
friendly with his family and his sisters
and kids and stuff but he had an amazing
big family and that was really hard to
lose this massive chunk of people
especially because I don't live in the
country you know I lost everybody by
myself yeah that's gonna be hard when
you get you sort of get attached to
everybody else yeah once you start doing
that then now you find yourself single
so you're not only single and you hate
dating and you're meeting this guy who's
a douchebag but then on top of it you're
like oh my god now I thought I was
married and I still had these
connections which is sort of a link to
him you know he just reminded me
although I totally keep forgetting is
that someone broke up with me because I
was on lost like the guy that I was
seeing when I got the part bit
disappointed but I've gotten it what my
dreams are coming true is Asians like
wait you just phone in that bloody
response and now after always like you
know what I don't really want to be with
someone that's gonna get recognized so
see you later I'm like I'm sorry but you
knew I it's like all these blokes along
the way like I don't like you I don't
like you successful
so what is that there's something
psychological there I'm sure you have a
therapist I'm not you know I don't know
what that is because I mean if you like
someone you just like hey I want to
support you what you do I'm happy for
you in fact if you're if they're not an
actor maybe it adds a little spice to
their life it's tit you know it's not
like you'd want to do I mean you're
dating you're married an actor isn't he
a director or like a writer or he's not
in the industry so he's not like in
Hollywood Hollywood he knows enough that
he understands what I do I love these
phrases here that's really good
now how do you know when you met him
what was different
so is it Marcus right mock-mock-mock
what was different about him than the
other guys that you're right away was
the first date where he did something
and you thought huh what was it we
didn't have a first date ever because we
have mutual friends in common and he was
in another relationship so it's sort of
gotten to know him over a long period of
time and then so it was kind of like a
slow get to know and then and then he
and his ex-girlfriend broke up and then
I haven't worked in ages I was oh my god
it was awful I was like 70 grand in debt
homeless I me and my dog couldn't even
stay together this is only in 2013
why were you $70,000 in debt I haven't
worked in ages is it still because I had
to borrow money and I like had a loan it
was awful I couldn't afford my car
anymore
this is boss lost yes yeah it was weird
it was like I was thinking coming off of
lost I'm like okay and then it was it
was not and then when I was working
maybe it was like a guess four or
something little which is a lot less
money than when you're a series regular
as you know so it kind of gotten really
really cracked so when I met more I had
that year in 2013 I tested for 11 pilots
and got zero
now what is that what does that do
psychologically to you does that give
you that did you fall in a depression
and you get anxiety was energy into
surrendering you know I mean because it
wasn't blow I'm not on the phone with my
team and I'm like I want you to go out
there and I want you to call everybody
and get feedback because the only common
denominator in all of this is me so if
it's something I'm doing wrong if it's
like my American accent was [ __ ] or they
didn't think I was connected to the
material whatever the [ __ ] it was I need
to know otherwise I don't even know if I
don't learn from this then what was the
point because this hurts and so they
went out and then they came back to me a
couple days later and they were like
none of it was your fault I'm like come
on piss off you know none of it be me
but it was a really weird it was like
one was like you know it was an
ethnicity thing out of my control and
another thing was like they had to go
Canadian visa wise it was all these
weird stupid little completely different
reason but talking outside of my control
so I heard like a come-to-jesus moment
like [ __ ] I'm just gonna have to
hashtag surrender and I just threw it
all up to the universe and just decided
to have a great summer instead and just
whatever it is what it is and that was
the summer that me and my husband fell
in love and I was in a really good mood
even those things were really crap cuz
love conquers all doesn't it but you
know in a way it's true when you really
are in love and you're that feeling you
have I don't I mean I haven't
experienced a lot in my life but I would
say that it's definitely top few
feelings that you get it's definitely
more exciting than going oh my god I got
this part when you're in love with
somebody and you're like there's that
that's I mean this is becoming apparent
is way more next level in terms of love
because it's a different kind of love
and it's like I will cut a [ __ ] I will
die I will throw myself into oncoming
traffic this like all of a sudden is
this person that you would literally do
anything for like you can get annoyed
and want to punch your spouse but with
your child it's like whatever you do you
think even he could [ __ ] in my face I'm
like I've got this any guys I'm sure be
different and when wish mushing
now oxytocin and like the feelings that
are released it's like better than any
drug and the lodge is like like inhaling
him get enough it's like such a high and
I'm a keynote it's really helped me get
through this pandemic and everything
because it's been a really rough time
for everybody and I think being out with
a shlush home has really kind of kept my
mood up the Jews did you think of at one
point what am I doing with my life
I'm gonna quit acting I'm gonna quit all
this [ __ ] it's just bringing me down
because you think about it's just like
you know you your life from day to day
it changes your emotions change with I
got a part or I got this callback or I
know I didn't so you're up and down up
and down and are you an emotional person
where you would feel each one you cry
like that I mean like lose your [ __ ]
yeah I'm so connected to my emotions
which is a good and a bad thing he saw
that early though right he saw like okay
she's emotional yeah I mean I don't hold
back myself I feel things which is a
blessing and a curse because I've had to
learn how to not take on other people
[ __ ] because I'm so sensitive to
someone's own in pain I'll cry with them
I'm feeling it too and it used to really
like yeah deplete my energy so much I
had nothing left to give myself did you
go to therapy about it did you like that
you did you speak to someone you do do
you still do that I've tried to sort of
learn tools to kind of hold space for
somebody that I love and be present and
be there for them but and then but not
completely connect to it energetically
where you can kind of just hold space
here be empathetic but they're not like
absorb it we are like oh god afterwards
you know so it's been only that's why I
think what you learn over time as you
get old I couldn't do that when I was
younger that's all you know every time I
talk to my friend Tom
he always has advice and I remember
throughout the years you say I know you
want to be in a relationship bad dude I
just want you to know one thing
imagine all your [ __ ]
now you've got all their [ __ ] yet all
their [ __ ] and all your [ __ ] I know you
think it's great in a there's moments
it's a lot dude it's a lot cuz their
[ __ ] is your [ __ ] if you don't want to
deal with their [ __ ]
it goes to [ __ ] I mean that one
sentiment that just eradicate all
relationship books like that's just it
sums it up that is relationships
relationships is taking that someone
else's bag [ __ ] the end it kind of is
and you know and it's also how much of
their [ __ ] can you handle you want to
like throw it in the doggy
you know trash can on the side of the
road it's a lot what's the best advice a
therapist ever gave because there's
certain things a therapist has told me
and I go oh my god you know little
things along the way what was it that
really nothing she let me waffle on for
a while little smirk on her face and
like waiting to give her response I'm
like what so you don't marry your father
dear you marry your dominant parent and
I just went mmm she's like I'm gonna
give you a minute and I August on that
rose I've married my mom completely I
mean that might be true for some people
but like for instance like look I love
my mother I wish you know I you know we
don't need to get in there that I just
want to say that I tried to marry
someone that is and not no disrespect
she's who she is and it's I just need I
can't marry someone like me or like my
mother I need to marry someone who is
sort of the antithesis of that someone
who kind of calms me tells me to shut
the [ __ ] up someone who I'm attract you
know so I don't know if that they've
been divorced for 15 years my dad
remarried and yet divorced my mom
to who who was the dominant parent out
which is like who wore the trials in the
relationship man it was really like you
know my mom was just off the wall so my
mom would walk into a room and we're
watching the Mets game
and all of a sudden she would just go
yeah [ __ ] my dad and then go I and this
storm out my mind I looked at my dad
he's like what's wrong with you yeah she
just said what was on her mind and
something no filter at all
she didn't know if she was making people
uncomfortable so she has a huge heart
but she's the opposite of my dad so my
dad was very reserved private I'd never
seen my dad naked one time I saw his
balls that upset him but you know she
was kind of out there so he was like III
was amazed sometimes how they were
together but then that you talked to my
grandmother my grandmother would be like
they he was crazy about her he was so
grateful so long and then I think it
just got you know because he wasn't a
jealous guy but she was sort of uh doing
things to provoke him and it just didn't
end well it just did not end well do you
think that there are there certain rules
with your marriage where you're like you
know just is he very comfortable with
himself where he doesn't you know does
he get jealous do you get jealous do you
how do you deal with all that stuff my
whole life it's definitely yeah I'm Way
more jealous but there's no like rules
or anything but I think this little
light is off understanding that like it
would be weird for me to like meet a
straight guy and then have lunch with
him like we don't you know what I mean
it's like any male friends of mine are
male friends the preed a.m. or they
don't want me sexually because they you
know again whatever so that's different
because like I don't meet a new guy and
have a new guy friends astray that's
weird
yeah so I mean are there certain things
that you guys feel like you have to tell
each other everything
like every last thing or is it just like
I trust you go do what you want I was
younger I always like wanted my
boyfriends to be like my girlfriend like
my best girlfriend to hear about my day
and up above a bar and then this was
also good advice from a therapist
she said he doesn't want to hear it I
don't remember who I was with at the
time she's like ninjas here blah blah
blah blah
when is she gonna get to the point and
when with women she's like what about
when you called a friend and I'm over
the crinkles you and I'm like oh my god
tell me everything wait I have to get a
bit Oh what were you worried was it
Tuesday it was it was Thursday all that
changes everything
wait a minute what were you wearing we
have to know all the details but all the
story and that's the muscles I've
learned to realize that strengthening my
female friendships improves my romantic
relationships because I'm never gonna
get what I want all of it from a man
because what women get from other women
is something that I don't think a man
can really give like the way that we
hang and talk [ __ ] and cry in each
other's arms like you get a different
kind of support from women do you think
women get meaner you know men can do
things that are hurtful and say things
but when women in other words when when
guys talk about women behind the woman's
back so if the guys are downstairs
talking about something the group of
Mellie and they could say things and
it's it's uh you know whatever shallow
it's this oh she have small boobs or oh
she had this oh really do you know guys
kids you know getting their little
groups and say they're [ __ ] do women get
just as bad all they're like oh my god
he's such a Oh
that guy's such great he's gross
somebody has the smallest dick like that
do they get you guys get in her [ __ ] but
I think I don't know I think when you're
in your 20s you might be friends with
people that aren't good for you or
people that could be [ __ ] to you and
tear you down but the best thing for me
about getting older is you don't waste
your energy on that so for me the female
friendships that I have now none of
these people would talk [ __ ] about me
behind my back nor I then because over
time you weed out all the dicks you know
so as you get older like for me it's
like my female friends it's like hanging
out on zoom or Skype in a pandemic with
a friend with a glass of wine suit
shield is way better than any therapy
session because those are the kind of
like friends that I have the chats that
we have we're after is you might have
mind-blowing moments where you have this
realization or something and it's like
and I grow just from hanging out with my
mates all right tell me tell me if I'm
wrong here I feel like women aren't from
what I gather from
friends other girls you know for
instance I have a friend she got
something done to her face uh
[Music]
immediately I can't hold anything back
I'm a close friend I just go what the
[ __ ] did you do what I didn't do
anything yeah you did don't [ __ ] lie
to me look at your look at your mouth
it's like briefcase handles I don't know
your toe don't lie to me come on now
when it will go oh my god you look I
know I'm doing your accent but you look
great oh no you're not oh no you're not
where I'm like someone asked me a
question it is rude to not I mean show
some propriety but how could I don't
like when women are too nice to their
friends they're too nice like no sweetie
you're wrong no one sees that tell them
what people say do you think I'm fat
honestly you're my best friend please
tell me I go look I think you're
beautiful inside out I'm but I will not
lie to you could you you lose a few
pounds sure we all could you put it in a
certain way but don't lie to them don't
sit there and go yeah or on my too
skinny and I didn't just I want people
around me who were honest not so much
that they think because I wanted to be
liked I didn't dare say something
negative to somebody and I also was so
terrified of hurting other people's
feelings that was always one of my
greatest fears was making somebody else
feel bad because I was bullied so much
growing up so I would be the person like
no no you know fine brilliant I love
your new lips I did I have to say I just
get more and more and more honest and I
just I don't want somebody's lies like
if I say to someone I'm feeling a bit
weird in my body the moment and I feel
like I need to lose a few pounds my best
friends will probably go well how can I
help you do that which is agreeing right
in a way that lifts me up and says how
can I be of service to you in achieving
that rather than like no no you're fine
it's all says that's movin I don't want
to be your [ __ ] friend it's like tell
me the truth listen you said earlier you
threw this away like it was nothing and
you know I'm gonna I'm a hammer you with
it you said you were bullied as a kid
yeah why were you bullied how old were
you
I was started when I was fool before
yeah there was this girl at my school
that basically believed me for the three
years of that school because in England
you have like infant school jr. and then
you go to secondary schools I just did
you say infant school I see the called
infants or it's called primary ok my
Marion secondary and it was horrible it
was almost like she was my captor or
something like she owned me it was
horrible I dreaded going to school and
made me feel sick to my stomach and then
when I went to another school and moved
away from her I had some pretty good
years and then another group swept in
and they all just decided to early me
together as a group this group of girls
and just ruined my time at that's called
junior school and then I went to another
school you move on to the next one and
then it happened there were these other
girls and they would like follow me on
the way to school and their bikes will
try and trip me up and push me twice do
you know the reason we're there certain
reason they call you certain names yeah
they were like cool like a posh [ __ ] and
things like that because we're I you
know in England how you speak determines
everything right and you were falling
Cambridge right yeah because the class
system is still very much in place your
accent determines how you're treated or
perceived by people you know so I think
I got into the group of friends and I
was like 14 that were posher than me
like you know their parents lived in
Cambridge because mummy and daddy
studied literature at the stage whereas
I'm a local that's from there like
generationally the English side my
family was from there and I think when I
got into this group of friends my accent
kind of kind of got a bit harsher so
then it pissed off the other people from
my previous birth who the [ __ ] you think
you are now do you think you're [ __ ]
special I know they would get their
friends like come and kick me at
lunchtime a nice to hide and hide and
eat my lunch I go for a bike ride at
lunchtime they eat my sandwich by myself
and how long did the flash through high
school up until I was 14 15 so it was
like the age of 4 to 14 so often armed
different people for a decade yeah do
you have any close friends from back
stuck with you I've got one two very
good friends from home but they that
happened after I kind of got away from
[ __ ] hated it ruined school I still have
nightmares about being is gonna wake up
drenched in sweat it's still very much
in me and and a part of me and it's been
it's definitely shaped Who I am and I
think it's why I'm still like a normal
not to toot my own horn but we people
don't ever change or when I started
acting it's like I can't because I I'm
still like this like chunky acne bullied
person inside still isn't that funny
doesn't isn't that funny
not that I'm just saying in general
because that's that's how I feel people
don't understand that but when things
happen to you when you're younger and
you're bullied or you're told you're
stupid or you told certain things it
doesn't matter how successful you are or
get for some reason those things still
stick with you even if they're almost
subliminal or subconscious I mean and
they're just they sort of find their way
out if you let them completely like you
know saged out of my experience is still
in there like I've definitely worked on
it in therapy and you know just try to
kind of like fix that part of myself but
I still it's still in me no because I
would say that like my biggest trigger
is being bullied so if I feel under
attack or if someone's coming after me
it's really hard for me to just be like
super chill about it and life or whether
rush off my back but it's like fighting
for 4 year old me going I've got this
because I'm trying to be for myself well
I didn't have then at the time and it's
it's really hard for me to stop doing it
I think you're not full I get stopped
acting from that in it I still yes I
still do that to if I feel like I'm if
somebody's condescending or making me
feel dumb it's almost a defense
mechanism where I'm starting to feel
like uh-uh and then I kind of get like
no you well
when it comes back uh but it comes and
different emotion comes out because I
don't want to let this crush me so what
I do is I kind of get mad I get feeling
in my chest I know it's wrong and I'm
like no no no that's not what I'm saying
and I will like there's no reason times
I'm like why are you even doing this and
it's because it does this ever come out
has this ever come out on a set have you
ever just really clashed with someone
where you're just like this person is
just I don't get it I feel like I'm
being bullied I feel like they're just
disrespecting me and you just want to
crush them all the time I don't think
it's ever happened on set where I felt
bullied in particular by a person other
negative things may have been happen
that maybe they were inappropriate or
con I'm kind of trying to nag me and put
me down which I guess is a form of
bullying I don't know not where I've
wanted to just like go completely postal
and just like get really English yeah
are you worried if you had to yeah yeah
I would I probably would don't more now
that for my son if someone tried to
bully him
I really hate bullying I just have no
patience for it and I really really hate
it if I when I find out that people are
being bullied I get really upset and I
think what can I can do how can I help
like and I think that's one of the
reasons why I've got such an amazing
connection with a lot of people that
watch to once upon a time because I met
so many people that suffered from it too
and it was really cathartic for me to
share my stories with my fans and listen
to theirs and sort of understand it you
know and kind of not let it take over
your life so that's been really cool in
a way you know I think the the bullying
thing is also gonna be very good you
having experienced that and raising a
son I would know because I'm not I don't
have a son but with Milo there's things
that you could learn that you've learned
that you could tell him that's that if
you didn't experience that maybe you
wouldn't have sort of
informed him and kind of gave him an
idea of like hey this is happening but
you can relate to it so you could sort
of maybe express how you feel and and
maybe educate him a little more on that
I don't regret anything about my past
and I also don't have pain about things
that happened to me because selfishly
you know it's made me a better actor and
I think you know I've worked with actors
that have had a fantastic childhoods
like the kind of people that you would
mean you know like what he was saying
about wishing to have different parents
and you know work with actors that have
amazing upbringing and were always
attractive and I find people like that
really hard to relate to and quite
boring so people have had like fucked-up
childhoods all used to be over way and
have acne like me I find a colorful and
interesting I've been through stuff and
those are the actors that I really like
to play with people that live you know
so it's just made me a more interesting
person it's gonna make me a better
parent so inside of you is supported by
better help online counseling and I
think you should listen to this one
folks um you know obviously these are
extraordinary times and if you're
struggling with stress anxiety or
depression you're not alone you're
obviously not alone you listen to this
show and we talk about that stuff and
all my guests tend to talk about that
and if you're on that patreon community
of mine you we talk about stress and
anxiety and you know therapy helps
people it just does better help offers
online licensed professional counselors
who are trained to listen and help and
better help counselor specialize in all
areas many areas I should say including
relationship conflict anxiety depression
as I said lost trauma so much more and
you can securely connect to your
counselor in a safe and private online
environment and everything you say is
confidential so that's important and
it's pretty easy I you know you just
fill out a questionnaire to help assess
your needs and get matched with a
counselor in under 48 hours easily
scheduled secure video or phone sessions
with your therapist Plus exchange
unlimited messages and if for any reason
you're unhappy with any of it you can
request a new one at any time no charge
you can get professional help when you
want wherever you want better help is an
affordable option in our listeners get
10% off your first month with the
discount code inside join over a million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states so there you go get started
today at better help calm / inside
that's better
HCl p.com / inside talk to a therapist
online and get help you like help for 30
minutes we just talked about all this
stuff this is what I like you know what
was amazing and playing such a broken
kind of damaged character on the once
was that she was so jealous that they
made that why the Wicked Witch went
green right that was why I was green
because I was green with envy and with
the relationship with my sister you know
I got to squirt like this is this one
director that just said you can just go
after her the entire episode like every
senior in just fight like a [ __ ] dog
and I've been waiting for someone to
give me permission I spend the whole
episode and I was talking to everybody
who tried alchemy overs as I was 4 in
everything just like the Exorcist was so
good when you first got uh lost was that
like a game changer did you know because
they told you what did they tell you
like oh it's just one episode it might
be - that you knew was gonna be the
longer that you can't just come on again
you know and I'm sure they gave you tons
of money - well no I wouldn't say tons
because it's ABC disney so it's not like
shushing shushing but it's like i
different contracts for different
seasons but it was like going into this
never about the money it was like okay I
am joining a brand-new machine that's
never been built before there's never
been anything like this before this is
actually a big [ __ ] deal because I
wasn't watching the show when I had the
audition and then I went to Barnes &
Noble at the Grove and got season 1 on
DVD and I'm like I'm gonna manifest this
I'm gonna watch every episode to pretend
I'm preparing for a role because I just
seen it see you know I was like back in
2007 when that was a big deal
and I was like I'm just gonna go for it
but then of course when I started
watching it I'm like oh this is amazing
how the [ __ ] have I not been watching
this for the past two years and am I
started watching it I'm like oh my god
I'm an idiot this is amazing and was it
intimidating getting on that set all of
somewhat your first scene wasn't your
first scene with a bunch of actors yeah
my first scene was with like and Slayer
and Claire that's right I remember that
scene my first day at work it was it was
epic so I had watched 66 episodes in
three weeks in preparation for my first
day at work because I joined an episode
like 402 and all three seasons were
already out on DVD so I had like two
weeks to like pack up and get ready to
go to Hawaii and I was watching the
season finale of season three in my
hotel and wait for Transpo to pick me up
and it all like the world is like going
there on their hands and knees I mean
and then like Rebecca went ready for you
and then I went straight into the next
thing it was the sickest thing I've ever
experienced in my life it was like a
climbed inside my Apple computer I was
like in the episode was intense was it
um
JJ wasn't directing a lot of them at
this point right he just was producing
it so you can really get to meet him
right but you one thing I always say is
when you audition you get a role at
least you know that that's that's the
way you're gonna play it because that's
why they cast you if you get an offer
it seems so cool like I got an offer for
that
it's not fun because you go on sitting
there like no no can you try it like
this like oh [ __ ] I don't know what I'm
doing here I've had that where I'm like
I got an offer and then I'm I'm doing
something they're like no I'm like what
you hired me there's something scary
about it but you knew like you had the
confidence you were there there wasn't
really molding it or it was sort of
that's what I'm saying
so to me I felt confident because they
liked my gun in the room so I felt like
I knew what I was doing it was once upon
a time that was an offer and I wasn't
they never said how they wanted me to
play it which was really nice and I got
to just kind of do my own thing and they
were like whatever you're doing we like
you know like okay were those long days
that had belonged days mm-hmm it was
cool because it was such a big ensemble
cast it wasn't like you know you were in
all the scenes and you know like with
small casts where you work all day all
day like ten series regulars plus all
the guest stars plus everybody else so
sometimes you know you might have two or
three great scenes only work two or
three days and then you'd have like five
days off since my that's nice I mean it
was it was wet and it was cold and it
was physically grueling and there was
lots of stunts and lots of rain and we
shot in the rain always cuz Vancouver as
it's technically a rain forest so for
six months the year it was raining and
we shot outside at night in the rain and
we just shot in the rain you know with
like a big scream pole and pushing and
what was crazy as I remember thinking to
be like four o'clock in the morning my
gowns are so heavy and wet for the rain
I wouldn't you know mud up to my knees
ba-ba-ba-ba-bom rain just hitting the
thing over our heads in the scene I'm
trying to shout over the rain like how
is this thing how is this usable footage
but then cut to you watch the episode
and they were able to like pull the rain
out like like nothing had happened and
like what yeah I mean that character I
mean you're playing an iconic and you by
the way you're not coming on right away
in the first freaking year you you
didn't come in off season three right
it's very similar experience to lost
we're kind of like going
started into a pre-existing here see
that's that's not easy though
maybe for you it is maybe your anomaly
because when you're on a show from the
beginning you're in the pilot it's
amazing in other ways where it's like
you're shadowing each nor baby and it's
not thing but then also if it fails it's
all on you you know and then I feel like
going into something that's already
really shiny I mean was such a blessing
to me because it was already here I knew
it was gonna am and how many pilots have
I done that never even saw the [ __ ]
light a day is so disappointing like at
least this work will be seen by people
it won't be completely for nothing you
know yeah the other question for that is
you know the musical episode did you say
well I just I watched him cuz I didn't
see the hob so did you sing in that yes
remember the lyrics of course I mean I
sometimes I sing of like over the past
year or two would get up on stage and
sing my song at conventions what were
the lyrics to the song oh it god is a
four-minute song to sing the four
minutes on so what are some of the works
like I'm wicked I'm green it's good we
can always win so it's like me winning
and gonna take my sister down there's
really cool because shoot my song was a
full day web just me in Oz with my
munchkins and it was the same as
shooting a music video it was so cool
and they play the song really loudly on
playback and then I really sang along
with it rather than mouthing it
otherwise your neck which I did never
thought because I'm not a singer if your
neck wouldn't move right if you're just
you know mouthing the work so I really
sang it all day long as well and came up
with the choreography and how long did
you have to learn the actual song I
think we had about three weeks they had
a singing teacher frozen la and then it
would Skype with us in Vancouver and
give his singing lessons and then we
recorded it like one session in a
recording studio and thank you and that
was it you know I have to ask you about
Meryl Streep that you come on because so
far you haven't told me you get nervous
at all but you had to be nervous in
front of Meryl Streep
first matter chug the beer go ahead now
you weren't nervous I could tell you
didn't my pants I don't know I just felt
very very excited and she's just so
normal and chill and present and kind
there was there was one time we were
sitting in her office when we were
shooting and there was that they were
doing something with the lighting but
they said like don't don't go to your
chairs can you just stay here we're just
gonna fix something so I remember my
heels are killing me and I was in like
you know her character's office I was
like stretching out on the on her couch
and like Meryl had her feet up in her
ugh slippers on her desk that she's
doing a crossword and I'm drinking my
latte and this other actress it was like
what is wrong with you I'm like what do
you mean she's like you're like lying
down and relax Camaro's you're like
stretching it out like but she just
genuinely made me feel and I felt like
really yummy energy did you ask to take
a picture with her or the brats I was
like don't do that guys I'm so not that
person ever give a [ __ ] why but I just
thought in my career what if it doesn't
get better than this
there's really nothing better than her
it's like doing a movie with the Queen
and then gonna I was I don't want to
regret it when I'm older but I didn't at
least ask
I thought worst-case scenario she could
say I'm not comfortable with that sorry
darling and then that would be fine too
so after I rapped I snuck up to her
trailer and I knocked on the door and
I'm like Meryl darling I'm so sorry
buddy I've wrapped it's just like
[Music]
question can't get in here she was so
nice so I had that same experience with
Robert Englund in 98 for urban legend it
was like what if it doesn't get better
than meeting Freddy Krueger I'm taking a
picture with Fred Krueger right now one
of my favorite films of all time and the
first-ever convention I did was a horror
she was there in Florida I've never been
to a convention in my life plus I was
signing so I didn't understand what
going on and then I heard one that
someone at my table say that Robert
Englund was there I'm like what where
and I jumped up and left my table and
I'm like running looking for Freddy and
he was doing photo ops and I walked in
he had no idea who I wasn't like oh yeah
and I like jumped in next to him and he
put like the blades around my face I
think oh my god nice guy I remember the
poster it said if Nancy doesn't wake up
screaming she won't wake up at all do
you know the later numbers though 910
never sleeps go again what's eleven
twelve eleven twelve going straight to
13 when I was 11 I had a full sized
poster Freddy Krueger of the door stuck
with blue tack on the back of my bedroom
door I could see him from bed doing this
I have him right there of a doll up
there of them sorry I mean I have so
yeah same [ __ ] fanny what's your
favorite Fred Krueger Freddy Krueger I
quote that once
I'll be the Busey you'd be the brain so
he cuts the guys many scouts that got
his brains like pulsating out I think I
like welcome to prime time [ __ ] in the
fourth one I think dream wears and then
also in the first one he goes Tina and
then he says this is God and he cuts his
fingers off all right these are
questions [ __ ] talking questions for a
Becca mater why Beck says Beck's a thing
for Becky
Rebecca mater
my husband actually really brought it
back some of the guys at school at my
guy friends used to call me backs like B
EC KS and then when my husband Lloyd was
here that he started calling back so I
love it when people call me that but
then it became B e^x rather than and he
always calls me back that doesn't call
me anything else and now you have a
thing with your brother at home with
Shawn and Becks
yes you
an Instagram and everyone calls my
parents I never call you backs I just
call you made her a lot of people call
me made everyone invites my agent my
whole team will call me later it's so
funny how people do different things for
me and then my niece's call me aunt
Becca I'm Rebecca this is shit-talking
questions for my patrons and you could
these are quick quick fire Ashley e how
long did it take to put on that green
makeup I got you beat it was like two
and a half for my baldness but that
wasn't my question
and IA how fun was it to play such an
iconic character as a Wicked Witch of
the West how long was the makeup process
we told you that now laughs that
character will be with me forever love
it love it love it love her yes sir who
do you miss most on the show the one
right then it just came to mind what was
that I was gonna say I don't miss any of
them because we're all still friends in
the world here in LA I'm friends with so
many people from that show jennifer
morrison was on the show i love her i
walked away with at least ten friends
that when you leave a show you're lucky
if you get one goodie Loes like at my
baby show half the room or one says
Marissa and what was one of the most
exciting or most challenging scenes to
do in once-upon-a-time
exciting definitely the musical episode
for short and then challenging would be
going like traipsing through mothers now
at 4 o'clock in the morning with walking
pneumonia and wanting to die and having
to like deliver a [ __ ] monologue or
no 20 minutes you know speech when I
couldn't breathe and wanted to die if so
hold dust off if you could make your own
character and once upon a time hood it
being what powers would you have and
would you use them for good or evil I
wouldn't want to be another character
other than the Wicked Witch of the West
and if I could have an extra power just
outside of it I've always wanted
I wouldn't mind stealing like Harry
Potter's invisibility cloak that love I
knew you were gonna say that and someone
just told me well I don't know about
Harry Potter but being invisible
and they said you know when people want
invisibility it could only be used for
one thing and that's bad that's a bad
thing if you would do good things you
want to be seen if you do bad things you
don't want to be seen hence invisibility
that's what I'll say
Lisa H and playing Zelena I said that
right how is it for your acting process
going from a villain to what some people
see as a good person do you feel her
character development was more of a
redemption story there was a definitely
an arc where I went from being less
psycho and less [ __ ] but I think the
vulnerable part of my character was
always there which was fun because it
wasn't like I was just angry and cold
from the beginning I was definitely
emotional and broke and I got to show
that throughout so at least that was
there it wasn't just like oh I was
really nasty and then I was really nice
it was it was a Kulak there was always
they always wrote places for me to show
my vulnerability from the beginning
which was cool Danny I like that Rebecca
describes herself as a fangirl on a
sci-fi geek what are your favorite shows
my god Game of Thrones I would say
probably number one I love that show my
audition for the pilot yeah I remember
the audition at HBO and I just had
surgery so I don't know how I remembered
lines what I did I was in the mix like
six weeks an age do interactions with
fans differ depending on which role they
associate you f the number one thing
that I notice in terms of if people
recognize recognize her when I'm out
when I go out without a stitch of makeup
on my hair back and go to Whole Foods
looking like crap in my Jimmy James
friends people though oh my god
Charlotte laws they love you and then if
I've made a bit of an effort and put my
things together people go oh my god
Zelena what's a good time always I never
get
the other one the other way around Dion
Kay any memorable moments on the set of
lofts that you remember I've lost who
was the diva on that set come on give me
something
there was a diva though I will tell you
how many divas were on that set 1 2 3
how many do you remember like oh they're
difficult they are difficult you won't
say the name the dog was the first
character I met on the set I was sitting
waiting for them to finish the scene and
he came in sat next to me my my heart
flutters like oh my god I'm so excited I
want to hear this diva it's so funny
because every once in a while work with
someone you're like man they just how
unhappy something's going on maybe
they're just going through a lot of
stuff that's what you have to do yet
together as long as it doesn't you know
as long as long as it doesn't affect my
work and as long as they don't be [ __ ]
to me you know what it's like you know
I've had some really challenging
financial chapters in my life really you
know but I've had nothing and then so
then when I'm working I just I really
try to kind of focus on the positive in
no matter what the situation just the
blessing of working and this is my happy
place and I'm in my chair yeah this is
why I do what I do so when I see someone
acting so poorly or being really unkind
to hair and makeup on PA I'm just like
[ __ ] off home then it has to be here you
know we're not saving lives making telly
and if you don't want to do it then
[ __ ] don't there's a million other
people that would cut their right arm
off to be sitting where you are I've no
patience for it
yeah something you've just lost me and
why I'm never gonna be friends with you
you're not a nice person
can I guess who it want no look I'd love
talking to you and it's been a while but
I always follow you an Instagram I just
I'm happy for you I genuinely am and I
know you went through a lot like you
know young age you were modeling and you
went to New York and you were then you
did some soap operas which you're
[ __ ] I don't know how anybody does
those how did they memorize 35 pages in
a [ __ ] day I would puke all over my
own penis I just say that but I'm just
happy for you and you're super talented
and you're you deserve all of it wait
what thank you that's really sweet
well you know the best part about this
interview is you mmm no Milo didn't wake
up crying yeah you were worried about
that he's out cold
there's a speed what's your handle so
people can follow you x mater bxm for
mother ID obviously if you listen to
those if you're this far along at home
with Sean and Becks you could look
listen to her and her brother Sean
that's our YouTube channel that we've
been doing to kind of just have
something to do during the pandemic and
stop bonkers what do you want to do
what's the next thing you'd like to do I
wanna do a multicam you know really be a
giant penis and be home for lunch time
to see my baby they always say that
multicam is the best job you ask any
actor I think I'm the only one in the
universe he thinks differently I don't
think it's easy I don't because I've
done it and and the reason why I get
because there's something about
everything's changing every day the
lines are changing this is changing and
all of a sudden Friday night you're
going up in front of an audience and you
could be learning lines and just I like
to so I like half hours or movies or one
I like to have the material where I
could really get into it I know it's
that material I don't like it just
things changing all the time
I'm just and I don't like that
you might lose a joke that you've really
attached to its back and it goes again
and it's it's it's definitely an
emotional roller coaster and I did a I
did a pilot with James burrows and Sean
Hayes in 2018 and like this is huge the
entire crew and set of riders were for
Will and Grace like it's a hit it's on
NBC it's definitely gonna get picked up
you know you spent we had two weeks
instead of one week to rehearse it and
we finally get to the end and then they
changed all of my lines on the night
never seen him before and they just hand
me a laptop and they're like so these
are the changes I'm gonna cut that bit
different way around the table and
hearing on you jokes okay and I'm like
okay let's go what did you [ __ ] up a lot
all these changes did you able to just
get them and deliver them easily yeah
but it wasn't always breezy I mean the
stakes were really [ __ ] high and I
was so nervous but then when I did it
and I crushed it and I gotta love the
high was like it was so high yeah I
remember them for anything is that me
I'm like all right Michael John's gonna
say this and then you're gonna say that
might for some reason this is when I
start feeling dumb again as they keep
her as a kid because I can't he's gonna
say that then he's gonna say that and
you're gonna say that so while they're
going I can't even listen because all I
could think about is the line I'm
supposed to say I just don't I don't
like that it's too stressful Foreman I
would do it but I always would say I
hope that they didn't change my [ __ ] and
some Tyra member my dad came one night
live a studio audience and they gave me
this monologue at the end and I remember
going I just went over at 1,000 times
because I'm you know I can't mess this
up and I remember on that's on on the
set I said it my gauri a repo reposition
did it again didn't really get it and
then and the director was cool enough to
go all right moving on and we picked it
up at the end when the audience was
going I love live theater but that stuff
is just like I don't I don't like it as
much maybe if I you know if you were
producing it you know what it means that
you are in control I know you never know
yeah it's true I want to I want to make
a horror movie that's my goal believe me
I know you could do it you could freakin
do it you can do it you could play crazy
I think you could play crazy hey listen
thank you for a lot of listen thank you
for allowing me to be inside you this
has been wonderful it felt so good thank
you so much I love you thank you guys a
great episode I like how open she she's
so silly right I mean she just lets go
and doesn't give a [ __ ]
Rebecca thank you for coming on I I hope
you guys keep doing your thing
and you know that live podcast was
Zachary Zachary Levi and I was supposed
to be July 2nd but obviously they had to
be pushed and it'll be later in the fall
so keep looking wait wait another month
you'll know it cuz I'll post everything
when we have it rescheduled at the right
time and again
hey the support the show the handles
Twitter Instagram it's pretty much
inside a podcast or Instagram and
Facebook inside a pod on Twitter email
your friends tell them to watch it and I
I would certainly appreciate that and
patrons
thank you again if you're interested go
to patreon.com/scishow and Napoleon
Dynamite and it's a blast why don't I
read off the wonderful patrons who make
this show possible a Nancy D Mary B Leah
s Patricia F Sarah V Yukiko Jill E Brian
H Lauren Cheney kopi Barry L it's
actually Barry I I mess it up every time
Angelina G Lee Jerry W Kevin R Emily K
Rob Bob B Robert B mmm
the brothers ones Bob ones Robert Jason
delvia Kristin Kay Amelia Oh Allison LJ
Cindy Raj Joshua D Emily BC JP Samantha
M Hamza be Hamza Bey hums V sorry I had
to say three times Jennifer and Stacey
be Carley t almost done here
rain Jennifer s Irene Jennifer s Janelle
B it out of the 272 Kimberly E Melissa
see Mikey Jake M Marisa n Judit D mom of
yellow Judit D or Amira Beth be Chris F
Sarah F Chad W Leanne V Darla W Jackie P
Rodrigo s Rachel see ray a Maya P megan
d de Mario Jennifer C Mahdi s Tiffany L
Kendrick hi Tiffany Kendrick F Ashley E
Kelly W Sigourney P Tom T Matt W Belinda
n and Benjamin R and if you're wondering
why I read off these names it's part of
the patreon these folks are what's
called the top tier and every episode at
the at the end I name their names off
and I wish I could take the time to talk
about each person or say how much I
appreciate them but they know it so
that's why you're hearing those names
why does he read these names well that's
part of the tier and I enjoy doing it
and these people keep the show going
so thank you to all these wonderful
patrons of mine and look for me on the
Instagram lives folks I'll be doing soon
I try to do one once a week if I can and
it's a lot of fun I always bring people
random folks and you meet some amazing
people we had this 16 year old girl who
answered and so there's a video of her
and I talking and she just kind of
seemed a little bit anxious or you know
sort of I don't know in a funk which I
understand and we we talked and I felt
like it just I felt like it just she she
said you know this made my night or
something like that it made my night it
just was nice to talk to someone and go
hey I remember being young and not be I
was and I wasn't popular
and you can tell this young lady was
really bright and I think she's gonna
have a great future so it was nice so
those Instagram lives support the show
whenever you can however you can
emailing tweeting all that stuff get it
out there help me help you terrible that
I quoted that one and that's all I have
to say so thank you and thank you for
allowing me to be inside each and every
one of you guys
[Music]